In 2026, coding agents will quietly
retire their first software platform.
Not because it's bad, simply because the
platform is unnecessary.
I am Dominic Turno. I am founder and CEO
of Resonate. Resonate is a durable
execution platform built with minimalism
and simplicity as its core technical
values. And these properties will play a
central role in this talk. At Resonate,
we have a working theory where software
engineering is headed.
General purpose implementations will
increasingly be replaced by bespoke
implementations
generated on demand, not as a new
library, a new framework, or a new
platform, but as a minimal extension of
the infrastructure that is already in
place.
If this theory holds true, reuse will
move upstream.
Instead of reusing a general purpose
implementation, we will reuse a
specification and we will derive a
bespoke implementation from it.
In fact, we can build many bespoke
implementations
tailor made for the infrastructure that
is already in place.
We just have to ask the agent. At this
point, the prompt is a platform.
Resonate is a dual execution platform.
We have an implementation of the
Resonate server. We have implementations
of the Resonate SDK for TypeScript,
Python, Rust, Go, and Java. So, we have
to ask what does this new reality mean
for us?
If implementations become generatable,
where does our value live? And our
answer, our value moves from
implementation to specification.
Now this changes how we think about
Resonate. The product is no longer the
implementation. The product is the
specification, the protocol.
And from that protocol, we want to
derive multiple server implementations.
One is a general purpose resonate
server, our reference implementation.
Others are implementations built with
infrastructure partners.
For customers and partners, this means
durable execution right on top of their
existing infrastructure with minimal
additional dependencies.
So the question is no longer can we
build a server. The question is can we
repeatedly synthesize trusted servers
from the same specification and if so
how?
When we talk about agentic engineering
we focus all of our attention on
verification.
How do we know the result is correct?
But today I want to focus on the
specification instead and more
importantly how can agents participate
in specifying the system not just
building or verifying it.
Now Resonate is partnering with multiple
infrastructure providers to bring
durable executions natively to their
technology stack. One of them is Senadia
the company behind Nats.io IO, an
open-source messaging system designed
for building modern distributed systems.
For the rest of this presentation, we
will use Resonate on Nats.io to explore
our agentic engineering practices. How
do we go from specification to
implementation?
First, we need to level set our mental
model.
This picture is a common view of agent
decoding. There's an agent. There's a
specification and then there's an
implementation
and for many applications that is enough
but it is not enough for what we are
trying to do
because we are not trying to generate
one implementation from a specification.
We are trying to generate multiple
target specific implementations from the
specification.
So the specification must not take any
aspect of an implementation into
account.
The specification must not assume a
concrete database schema or concrete
indices.
The specification must not even assume a
relational database with tables and
transactions at all. It must not assume
a key value store. It must not assume
weak consistency. It must not assume
strong consistency.
The specification must be abstract.
only the implementation must be
concrete.
So we ask the agent to follow the
abstract specification and generate a
concrete implementation.
Specifically at first we ask the agent
build a resonate server in rust on top
of posgress
and the agent failed.
The gap between the abstract
specification and the concrete
implementation was too large.
The agent generated a system that worked
on the happy path. It passed the basic
tests, but it was not correct. It broke
on the concurrency. It broke on the
process failure. It broke on the network
failure. The implementation was closer
to a prototype, but not a production
system.
So we amended the process. Instead of
asking the agent to jump directly from
abstract spec to concrete
implementation, we inserted an
intermediary artifact, the concrete
specification.
That concrete specification was derived
interactively with the agent. But the
human was the main driver.
For Postgress that meant making target
specific decisions explicit, the data
schema, the indices, the SQL queries,
the transaction boundaries.
Once those decisions were written down,
the agent was indeed able to implement
the production system. So this worked,
but it also revealed the limitations.
The agent helped us build the system,
but the agent did not help us design the
system.
And if the specification is a reusable
product, then that's not enough.
Now the next step is obvious. Agents
have to move upstream.
But how?
When we started building Resonate on
Natio, we changed the question.
We did not ask can the agent build the
production system. Instead we ask what
does the agent need in order to design
the system first and build the system
second.
So we gave the agent access to a
deterministic simulation environment.
And we gave it a different task.
Do not build the production system.
Build a simulated implementation.
The simulated implementation is not the
product.
It is executable design.
Its purpose is to discover the correct
algorithm under partial order under
partial failure. And once these
algorithms are discovered, tested and
verified in simulation, then we ask the
agent to write the concrete
specification.
And only then do we ask the agent to
write the production implementation.
So the process becomes abstract
specification,
simulation implementation,
concrete specification and then concrete
implementation.
This is a point where the agent moves
upstream.
Humans are still involved in the design
process, but now the agent is a driver.
Two ingredients make this possible.
Minimalism and simplicity.
Unfortunately, minimalism and simplicity
are not the starting point. They are the
finish line. We spent three years making
the protocol smaller and simpler. Every
time we ran into a problem, we ask,
"What can we take away? What abstraction
can we erase? What property can we
remove? What relationship can we break?"
The result is a very small protocol
centered around two objects, a durable
promise and a durable task.
That simplicity matters because even
simple concurrent distributed protocol
have a complex state and behavior space.
So in other terms, implementing even
simple protocols on top of a few simple
primitives is tough.
Let's make this concrete with nats.nats
NATS gives us a small set of primitives
we can build on cues, a key value store
and delayed or scheduled messages.
These are not resonate concepts. These
are the concepts of the target platform.
So the design question becomes how can
we express the resonate protocol using
only these primitives?
Let's focus on the key value store.
The key value store is versioned. We
create a key with value fu. Then we
update it to bar. Then we update it to
bass. So the latest value is bass at
version two.
Most of the time when we read the key
that is exactly what we get,
a fresh read.
And if all reads were fresh, the design
would be straightforward.
But sometimes the read is stale.
Here the latest value is still bass at
version two.
But the read returns fu at version zero.
That is not corruption.
That is not a bug in the key value
store.
That is a valid read under the
consistency model of the target
platform.
And that matters because our
implementation cannot be correct only
when the target behaves conveniently.
The implementation has to be correct
when the target behaves legally.
So the simulation environment has to
expose exactly this kind of behavior.
Fresh reads, stale reads, and the
version information that tells us which
world we are in.
Unfortunately, we do not know the read
was stale simply by reading. We will
find out later when we try to write
here. We read version zero. So, we try
to update version zero.
But the key has already moved on. The
right fails.
That is the moment the target tells us
the world you saw is not the current
world.
Building always correct applications on
top of a concurrency model that allows
occasional stale reads is not simple.
Not for humans, not for agents.
So how do we set up our agent for
success? What tools does our agent need
to ace this task instead of falling flat
on its face?
Agents thrive on feedback. immediate
unambiguous feedback.
Not just feedback that shows this went
wrong.
Feedback that shows why and how this
went wrong.
What stale value was returned? What
logic was triggered, what right failed
and which invariant broke because of
that.
So we built a deterministic simulation
testing environment in Python and inside
that environment we simulated the parts
of nuts io we depend on.
Here for example is the simulated key
value store.
It keeps a full version history for
every key
on get the simulated store sometimes
return the latest version. But sometimes
controlled by the deterministic random
generator the store returns an older
version.
On update the store enforces optimistic
concurrency. The right only succeeds if
the version you read is still the latest
version otherwise it raises.
This gives the agent a store that
behaves like the real store in the ways
that matter for correctness. But unlike
the real target, the simulation is
deterministic, it's repeatable, and it's
inspectable.
So when the agent writes the wrong
algorithm, we can reproduce the exact
execution that broke it and the agent
can repair the algorithm against that
trace.
But deterministic simulation does more
than just inject stale reads.
It lets us expose facts the real
platform hides.
We call this the forbidden fruit.
In production, when you read from the
key value store, you only get the value
in the version you observed. You do not
get to know whether that read was fresh
or stale. You do not get to see the
latest value you missed and you
shouldn't get that information because
real code cannot depend on it.
But in simulation we can record it.
Here every get emits a trace event. If
the read is fresh the trace says this
was fresh. If the read is stale the
trace says this was stale. this is what
you got and this is what the latest
value was.
That information is forbidden to the
algorithm, but it is incredibly useful
to the agent.
It lets us explore failures in terms the
agent can act on.
Now, this is what a trace event looks
like.
The production code only receives the
result.
It sees the promise was pending.
This is all the real platform would tell
us.
But the simulation also records the type
of the read. This read was a stale read.
And it records the latest value that was
hidden from the algorithm.
The latest value says the same promise
is already settled.
That difference is exactly the kind of
fact an agent needs when it's debugging
a distributed algorithm.
Not just the invariant failed,
but the invariant failed because the
algorithm made a decision from a stale
view of the world.
Again, the algorithm is not allowed to
depend on this information, but the
agent is allowed to use it to explain
why the algorithm it designed was wrong.
Cause and effect becomes visible.
The agent does not just learn that the
system is wrong. It learns why the
system is wrong.
And with this approach, the agent was
able to close the gap.
First,
the agent built a proof of concept in
the deterministic simulator
verified by first testing.
From the proof of concept, the agent
derived a concrete specification
where we already knew the algorithm was
correct.
And like before, from the concrete
specification,
the agent derived an implementation.
Deterministic simulation lets agents
participate in the design, not just in
the implementation.
Humans
are still in the design process, but
this time the agent is the driver. From
a single abstract specification, the
agent designed and built the platform
via simulation to concrete specification
to concrete implementation.
The prompt is a platform and the
specification is a product. Thank you
very much for watching. If you have any
questions, please don't hesitate to
reach out. You will find me in resonates
discord.